[Music]
in everything's racist by Tiff's chair
oh yeah
spit on my face Tiffany oh yeah well
that's what you buy what they're saying
yeah you're probably thinking I never
wished I was a chair so bad yeah sit on
my face girl you're flattered but what
if that kid's face was actually one of
the wheels and it's facing the ground
see you got a pin point which body part
you want to be you want to be this do
you do that [ __ ] they always trick you
in or you wish for get the wish I feel
like jokes on them if their lips are on
my chair and they got nothing but
[ __ ] people now want the Spanish word
for black change because it sounds
racist I had this happen to me in person
thought of you immediately when I read
what do they say I don't know if I was
with you yet but I was at Michaels and
then I was on the in the aisle where
they have like all the markers and stuff
but you know how they have them like one
by one like it's just kind of displayed
so this lady our co-worker
we're looking at different colors and
then the the black lady look that she
goes oh hell naw what but the friend was
a lot the ER like she look Hispanic and
then she goes this says Negro on it and
then the front starts laughing like it's
my girl they get them into black I love
your impersonation of a black woman
though can we do it again oh hell nah I
didn't person 8 that's literally what
she did I'm just trying to like put
myself back in there and try to like
mimic what I heard she was outraged
what's so funny is that she's so
ignorant I shouldn't know that that was
the word for black for thousands of
years Spanish language a lot of people I
guess she wasn't around maybe maybe just
says Negro yes and she's like yeah when
that reminds me of Steven Seagal
impersonating a black person
I showed this full of video to be good
that [ __ ] was hilarious no money because
like you know how Steven Seagal is a
officer like partying straight up
I think Oklahoma or somewhere and
they're doing this like TV special on it
and so he's speaking like normally like
Steven Seagal speak like a white man
then when there's a black back all of a
sudden it changes like no he's dead
serious
weird died dude I was like that was so
unnecessary why did he have to say why
do you have to say like yeah and the
black say that with my yellow glasses I
thought it's ridiculous yeah well
similar to geo story here there was this
girl named Becky she tweeted out two
photos of her dog and she captioned it
with me naked always missing please if
anyone sees him message me so this is
Becky she's and this is the tweet
negative yeah cutie at all but the new
cut years old and then so it's a black
dog name that negative is used in
Spanish as a color is races as [ __ ] I
[Music]
saw this photo where this person this
person took a photo of this eyeliner and
then wrote the caption along the lines
of like how upset she was and how she'll
never support this makeup company
because this black I remember that I
remember seeing that yeah it had like
like um the English language the Latin
and then it I think it's something in
France like English Spanish like never
again why I purchase I was like no it's
so sad that's a reflection of I think a
lot of no not even that just like
American people who think that America
is the only country in the [ __ ] world
so cent they don't understand that
there's first of all America is a newer
country first of all you know I mean so
there's already history way before that
pre sees this country yeah so it's very
odd like I don't get that means black
and Spanish but it doesn't mean black
people exactly so then she's responding
you definitely ain't gonna find that dog
now with the name like that
this is excellent you knew what you did
by calling your dog that all that else
you are dumb as [ __ ] and then now people
are supporting her Becky saying I'm so
sorry about your missing dog and
everyone's ignorant oh my [ __ ] god I
hope you find him next one yeah people
really just always ready to pull the
race card it's so aggravating she
clearly is Hispanic I'd even take
Spanish and I know Negro means black and
then your dog is black I really hope you
find it girl ignore these people
everything and then and then that
previous person she's saying something
like I said what I said it's racist and
then someone responds your touch that
I'm stating the obvious
oh no homegirl is reaching over here
black as a color the dog is black and so
so his name is black if you feel
offended you might be the problem this
is just like if they named a dog brownie
for being brown yeah like my doggie
brown or yellow or white II dare you
[ __ ] name a yellow lab is an agent
his eyes are huge so you're telling a
whole culture that changed their
language even though that's not what it
means in that language cuz like there's
so many words from out like like in
Vietnamese right there's like there's
like phat PHA T like someone's name but
is that fat shaming yeah right or like
or like fook F like pH you see right but
it could be read as [ __ ] and you could
tell them don't don't name people that
anymore your you should change it
because it sounds like [ __ ] it's like
the same thing that's like what people
say like context matters a lot
so there's a guy that I met last week
who's not from here and he just
shortened the word tasted [ __ ]
he doesn't realize that that's a
derogatory term here in America yeah
yeah is he Japanese Korean and they say
that in Australia just go you the
Oriental in Australia yeah yeah yeah so
it's it's different yeah I mean so he
didn't really know that [ __ ] and the
funny thing is he actually owns a
Japanese Hawaiian restaurant not in the
States though yeah somewhere else so he
was like oh [ __ ] I didn't know I was
cracking the [ __ ] up ya see I just did
it just did the America revolves like
the whole world yeah yeah yeah I mean by
reacting that way cuz uh and I think in
Britain they call East Asians Orientals
and then they call Southeast Asians like
Asians or they call in they call Indians
Asians yeah so it's like oh they just I
don't know cuz you can't say oriental
out here yeah it's a weird this is a rug
yeah cuz I think oriental is for things
not for people or whatever I don't know
the real reason but yeah why sounds
great ignorant here very archaic but old
why people call me oriental I don't get
like my panties in a bunch
yeah it's just the English that they
learn yeah even my mom like she says
oriental yes so she grew up in Taiwan
she she learned British English so if
she spells color at Co L oh you are well
cool it's toasted all your fine oriental
nice like she she still speak like that
holding a zipper head come here my
friend was a part of a party crew called
oriental bad boys that sounds looking
and my friend was a part of a gang
called the oriental lazy boys very odd
motivated singers even like a bunch of
couches
yeah oriental lazy boys I dare you to
come here I'm not gonna do [ __ ]
help my cupholders but I don't know I
think people get their panties in a
bunch a lot they stop I think just feel
like people can't wait to get their
panties in a bunch right there just like
specially right now give me a reason I
freaked out yeah every little thing like
you have to be careful it's funny that
they're getting offended because of
their interpretation and ignorance like
they don't understand Spanish they
literally think they named it be grown
from like the [ __ ] slave days like
that stupid as [ __ ] but people love to
get angry because I when I did this the
video about Aziz they're like you
completely misinformed everybody about
the stories wrong I was like that's
funny because I actually quoted what was
written from that girl's day you know
but they just want to write anything
yeah no but people trash those people to
billing what the [ __ ] are you talking
about he literally quoted what the girl
said was like all right it's funny when
people misunderstand something and they
think they know more than the person
that made that statement yeah and
they're like you're so dumb you totally
missed the point and it's like why is
there Steve yes sometimes those people
I'm like you have to be patrolling right
now like there's no way you're for sure
serious about certain stupid things like
that when they bring it out and like
pointed out like for example in one of
the recent videos Casey said something
about the book that you gave him and how
he's cooking from it and he literally
said like who who is the author and he
was a comment that was like wait isn't
that book from that person and it's like
you're just trolling now come on like we
clearly said it why are you even
mentioning anything like biggest wants
you to respond to them like recently
there was a comment about like I said if
I'm comedies I'm from the crapper but it
was it was because here we're opening a
new business like this matcha green tea
joint and they're like well I hope it's
not like you know barbell when they make
you pay for the weights then I was like
you know I wrote back and I was like
well number one
chill out yeah because it's I I don't
like false claims either so just kinda
add it right back to almost listen
number one if you do want to go to that
gym you ain't got to go number two if
they don't charge for weights number
three most likely you don't work out you
wouldn't be complaining about this I
like well there's like there's other
business like 24 and I was like then you
could go to plan that's like comparing
fast-food to like a steakhouse exactly
and they just it didn't really make
sense so I was like okay charge for the
weights watch out that's that's like
absurd as like saying like yeah well
it's not like barbell where where they
force you to buy [ __ ] snow cones yeah
it's like ludicrous like what the [ __ ]
are you so the weights there's like a
quarter slot in the dumbbell you know
four quarters is bound to that point you
know I wrote back and they get real big
it's like oh thanks for responding to me
I was like oh they just want to just
wanting to get a reaction exactly an
attention I only talk [ __ ] about your
mom to get attention yeah I have to beat
you up oh my god you responded
[Music]